what makes mars attacks more relatable
today than ever before which movies beat
the film at the box office how close did
it come to winning an oscar stay tuned
to find out
as it turns out mars attacks wasn't an
original idea conjured up out of thin
air by tim burton
they may not be as popular as the source
material for other burton projects like
batman or alice in wonderland but the
trading cards that mars attacks is based
on still have a significant pop culture
legacy they were first unleashed into
the world in 1962 and quickly gained
notoriety for depicting aliens attacking
humans in vivid violent detail
decades before the likes of independence
day made it commonplace to destroy
sacrosanct locales and blockbuster
flicks the mars attacks trading cards
were blowing up the golden gate bridge
and setting fire to the white house
parents were outraged but kids were
enamored though these cards weren't
originally around for a very long time
their distinctive visuals and grotesque
humor left a lasting impact on the era's
youngsters they even proved enduring
enough to inspire a big budget movie
decades after they first petrified the
populace
the original mars attacks trading cards
weren't the only ones terrifying
children with horrifying imagery the
dinosaurs attack cards of the 1980s were
just as scary as they depicted dinos
attacking unfortunate humans and each
other these intense illustrations
sparked the imaginations of kids
everywhere and they still inspire plenty
of nostalgia to this day considering
that level of fondness it's no surprise
that a film adaptation of these cards
was once in development there was also a
dinosaur's attack comic series and the
first issue released in 1991 reported
that a film version of the property was
in development
but tim burton ultimately put that
project aside in favor of adapting mars
attacks once jurassic park became a huge
hit a pop culture juggernaut like that
would have made a dinosaur's attack
movie seem like a cheap cash grab
so with that project still as dead as a
t-rex those yearning to see tim burton's
take on dinos will just have to keep on
waiting many of tim burton's films are
explicitly linked to the movies that
inspired him to become a filmmaker in
the first place 1994's ed wood for
example offered him the chance to pay
homage to a famous or infamous b-movie
director mars attacks is no exception
and it even served as another chance for
burton to tip his hat to the works of ed
wood as the director explained to arts
beat la in 1996
i wanted to do something fun with a
bunch of martians with big brains
basically make a modern version of plan
9 from outer space or the war of the
worlds
burton was also of course inspired by
the mars attacks trading cards
particularly how they fused gross out
sci-fi elements with titillating imagery
according to burton this was very much
in the spirit of the 60s kind of sci-fi
movies that i was trying to recreate and
i remember always liking those movies
where there was some sort of weird alien
girl paying tribute to seminal works of
oddball entertainment has worked like
gangbusters for burton over the course
of his career and mars attacks is just
one spectacular example
typically quirky sci-fi movies that pay
tribute to something like trading cards
don't end up with particularly
star-studded rosters but the mars
attacks cast is absolutely packed with
a-list talent some of the famous faces
include jack nicholson glenn close
michael j fox danny devito and even a
cameo appearance from singer tom jones
and that barely even scratches the
surface getting so many big names for
mars attacks was more than just
something done to appease the marketing
department it was a conscious choice on
tim burton's part in order to further
challenge himself as a filmmaker as he
explained to artsbeat la
the only time i had ventured into
bringing together several high-profile
stars was for the batman movies and here
i wanted to repeat this experience on an
even bigger scale there are more than 20
lead roles in mars attacks so it was
quite a challenge for me to put together
this cast luckily this assortment of big
name performers threw themselves into
this uniquely goofy world with gusto
proving their ability to fit right into
burton's imaginative vision
huh calvin autograph anybody got a pen
today every movie from avengers end game
to hello my name is doris gets an
internet-based marketing campaign but
back in 1996 when the mars attacks team
was tasked with building hype internet
marketing for movies was still in its
infancy
it was so much of an event when films
got promotional websites back then that
entertainment weekly ran articles
examining every instance within a
calendar year ew writer bob strauss gave
the mars attack's website a b he offered
praise for how many behind the scenes
details it offered including sketches
from tim burton himself however he
criticized it for an overall lack of
distinction strauss's breakdown of the
site which featured cast bios and links
to relevant sites paints a bare bones
picture
it certainly seemed to have lacked the
kind of audience engagement elements
that are more typical of today's virtual
movie marketing but these were the early
days of online promotion so it's fair to
cut it a little slack movies like mars
attacks deserve our respect for paving
the road for modern marketing without
them we may never have ended up with
viral tick-tock dances
it may sound like a fantasy when
compared to today's cinematic landscape
but there was a time when cgi wasn't
absolutely everywhere as late as the mid
90s this technology was still limited to
only the most major blockbusters
but then slowly but surely those films
began popularizing the idea that digital
wizardry could do just about anything
anyone could imagine
that included realizing weird-looking
alien invaders who keep coming up with
cartoonish ways of dispatching humanity
tim burton has tended to embrace old
school methods of storytelling and
visual effects in many of his projects
but the unique aesthetic of mars attacks
necessitated the use of modern
technology as the director admitted to
artsbeat la i knew we had to create the
aliens with the help of cgi animation
every type of animation has a different
vibe and it's something you can really
analyze and there is something about the
computer medium that seem to work with
these characters because they are all
the same and they have a certain jumping
quality to their movement
computer generated animation did indeed
turn out to be a good fit for the other
worldly characters of mars attacks
allowing it to serve as a shining
example of the 90s cg boom
mars attacks received mixed marks from
critics upon its initial release and the
academy awards have a long-standing
hesitancy towards recognizing science
fiction films when you consider these
two facts together it's awfully apparent
that this film had little hope of
scoring some oscar's love but there was
still the possibility that it could
manage to snag a sliver of golden glory
for a best visual effects nomination
this dream looked like it might become a
reality when in january 1997 variety
reported that mars attacks was indeed
one of seven movies shortlisted for a
nomination in that category alongside
the likes of mission impossible and the
nutty professor
at the time shortlisted titles were
whittled down to three final nominees
who would then compete on oscar night
considering that burton's batman returns
had been nominated for visual effects a
few years earlier these hopes weren't
without precedent so a golden trophy for
mars attacks really did seem possible
within this brief window of optimism
sadly though mars attacks made it no
further in the oscar race
when the official nominees for best
visual effects at the 69th academy
awards were announced independence day
twister and dragon heart made it in
while mars attacks was nowhere to be
found what is wrong with you people
it's hard to imagine a tim burton movie
without an accompanying score from
composer danny elfman over the decades
elfman has translated burton's
distinctive spirit into a wide
assortment of music ranging from the
moodily epic queues of batman movies to
the darkly whimsical tones of charlie
and the chocolate factory for mars
attacks elfman channeled mid 20th
century music to match the retro visual
aesthetic of the film and pay tribute to
its source material even an unfinished
clip from mars attacks proved to be so
vividly imagined that it got elfman's
creative juices flowing it was pretty
much a piece of cake for this
experienced composer to conjure up the
necessary music
as he told collider in 2019 i saw the
opening for mars attacks when tim showed
me just a simple pre-viz version and i
said hold the film i ran out into the
lobby of the theater and i started
making all of these notes to myself for
what became the theme
usually it's much harder than that
with this sudden burst of creativity one
of the most unforgettable parts of mars
attacks was firmly cemented the music
by the time mars attacks hit theaters in
december of 1996 tim burton had
developed a reputation for helming
lucrative fare thanks to the likes of
beetlejuice batman and batman returns
alas mars attacks ended up being a step
backwards in terms of box office prowess
grossing 37.7 million dollars
domestically the film ultimately earned
just half of what beetlejuice amassed
eight years prior it also came in below
what batman and batman returns earned in
just their opening weekend the zany
comedic sensibilities of mars attacks
ended up resonating a little bit more
overseas where the quirky feature
grossed enough to put the worldwide box
office total at 101 million dollars
still the lackluster reception remains
notable considering its pedigree in
front of and behind the camera perhaps
mars attacks was seen as too much of an
independence day clone by the general
public maybe the exposed brains were a
little too creepy or perhaps its trading
card origin was just too niche here's
one thing we do know for certain
december 1996 saw the release of a
couple of mega hit movies in the forms
of jerry maguire and screen clearly more
moviegoers rushed out to see those films
instead of the considerably more
expensive mars attacks burton had
already experienced box office
disappointment a couple of years earlier
with ed wood but this was his first
genuine attempted blockbuster to come up
noticeably short why can't we all just
get along
[Music]
[Applause]
at the time of its release critics
praised mars attacks for its visual
effects and strong performances but they
took umbrage with its emphasis on
stylized dark gags over compelling
characters
all of the anarchic mayhem on display
just wasn't to everyone's tastes these
lukewarm notices made mars attacks a
noticeable step down in terms of
critical reception from prior burden
efforts like beetlejuice but in the
decades since it first hit theaters mars
attacks has managed to endure quite
nicely in the public consciousness
websites like collider and consequence
have published lengthy essays extolling
its virtues with the latter site
praising it for how much it commits to
old-school cinema homages and gruesome
violence
steve dash of slate meanwhile opened
that mars attacks has only grown more
relevant since its 1996 debut thanks to
its depiction of politicians as being
utterly inept in the face of global
catastrophe daesh also praised the film
for committing to the idea that a war
between otherworldly invaders and human
beings would be an incredibly one-sided
affair in favor of the martians the
franchise's legacy can also be seen in
the enduring popularity of the trading
cards with new sets arriving in 2021
mars attacks may not have been
universally beloved upon its initial
release but some of its most outlandish
qualities have aged remarkably well
today it's treasured by the fans who
understand what it's going for and
recognize it as a standout effort in
burton's filmography so i guess like
now we just have to
start over and start rebuilding
everything
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you